hi guys welcome to the just really
things youtube channel if you've been
following my tic tac you'll know
i'm doing rejection therapy and
basically rejection therapy is where you
do
something every day to get rejected like
your goal
is to get rejected every single day
basically
you go out looking for rejection
basically to do it so much that you just
don't care anymore
now i have the number of the
president of the milwaukee bucks don't
ask me how
sales basically i'm nervous i don't want
to do it i don't want to do it
but i'm going to call him and ask him if
i can
interview him on how he became so
successful for my youtube channel
but i don't even know what i'm going to
say should i write that out first
but it doesn't matter because i'm
looking i'm looking for rejection
so it doesn't even matter what i say i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna do it oh my god what if he
doesn't answer what do i say
what do i say why am i so afraid of this
so what i say say my name is pearl davis
i run a youtube channel
with 15 000 subscribers i wanted to see
if i could interview you and how you
became so successful
that sounds good right okay just click
the button
click the button hannah click the button
you can do it you can do it
peter fargan is not available record
your message at the tone
when you are finished hang up or press
pound for more options
hi peter my name is pearl davis i run a
youtube channel with 15 000
subscribers and i wanted to see if i
could interview you on your success if
this is something that you'd be
interested in
give me a call back at 847. oh my god
oh my god i was so nervous what if he
calls me back
does that count as a rejection that
should that counts that counts
at 100 counts it's my rejection for the
day he probably won't call me back
what are the odds right i'm gonna send
him a text too because i'm annoying
i want the nose i want to get to the
point where i can get a no like to my
face it won't even bother me